social distancing measures and lockdown
procedures are being put to the test
this morning as the country endures a
major surge of coronavirus cases in
hard-hit Florida Disneyworld is going
against the grain by reopening two of
its Orlando area parks today on Friday
bars in seven Nevada counties were
ordered to close again in an effort to
stop the spread of the virus also on
Friday another single day record was
broken with more than 66 thousand new
cases of the virus reported it brings
the total to more than 3.1 million
infections and more than 134 thousand
deaths Michael George is in Garden City
in New York at a mall that just got the
OK to reopen this morning Michael good
morning Dana good morning just yesterday
this mall reopened to the public here on
Long Island it's a step forward for New
York at a time when much of the country
is moving backwards scrambling to shut
down again as the virus is spreading to
more than 60,000 people a day bars
restaurants and the young made their way
into the crosshairs of governors of
southern states where the virus is
surging this executive order will
prohibit the sale of alcohol alcoholic
beverages in all South Carolina
restaurants and bars after 11 p.m.
South Carolina Governor Henry McMaster
threatened to strip liquor licenses from
violating proprietors at a Kentucky Test
Site bartender Michael whittler knows
what can happen after 11 p.m.
once it gets too late at night it's just
unbelievable it's been pretty nuts
enough to make you want to give you
tested in Tennessee Shelby County
restaurants require customers to fork
over their contact information before
they'll be seated infectious disease dr.
Manoj Jain is on the local task force
that mandated the rule I think it's
really important to have people's names
and phone numbers because if there was
someone who was positive in that
restaurant at the same time then the
owners can tell everyone else chef and
owner Michael Patrick will hang on to
the information and seating charts for
the better part of a month to help trace
patrons who test positive
I would hate for
god forbid someone to get sick here but
I would feel like it was a public
obligation to let people know who eight
years for some crowded restaurants and
bars are seen as a toxic cocktail then
when the young are added in many of the
young people in our state as well as
around the country seemed not to be
taking the virus as seriously as they
should for months many young people
ignored safety measures and others
politicized the pandemic the groundwork
for breaking this week's case Records
was laid a record-setting 63 thousand
two hundred new cases in a single day on
Thursday at the end of April the one day
record was a little over 36,000
according to Johns Hopkins University
Florida alone had 11,000 new cases
Friday while Arizona has one in four
people testing positive while this week
to the country's three most populous
states Florida Texas and California
reported their highest single day death
tolls with Texas hospitals filling up
the governor slow to Institute safety
measures in the first place now stands
for a state that's paying the price
things will get worse the deaths that we
are seeing those are people who likely
contracted Cova 19 in late May now back
when New York was in its darkest hour it
was other states that stepped up sending
respirators doctors and nurses now it's
New York's turn to return the favor the
state is sending Florida enough of the
antiviral drug remedy severe to treat
280 patients Michelle it was tough to
live through and now to watch others go
through it equally as tough thank you
Michael